[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance there's a lot more shoes to
drop from this centipede said John
McCain about Trump and Russia
shortly after Trump got rid of the
United States Attorney for the Southern
District of New York as part of what
might have been a political purge Trump
saw Sean Hannity suggest on cable only
this US attorney wouldn't resign so
Trump fired him in a Saturday massacre
you know like Watergate and then we
reminded the guy he'd fired had
prosecuted and put into prison a Russian
spy was based in New York posing as a
banker and another Russian mobster who
ran one of New York's highest stakes
illegal poker games usually in an
apartment at Trump Tower and then the
guy he fired was banned from Russia by
Vladimir Putin it's not just that
McCain's analogy is apt it is as if
there are no shoes on the Trump Human
Centipede that are not about Russia
Russia Russia Russia Trump claims his
phones were tapped then Kellyanne
Conway emerges from wherever she was
hiding to suggest that never mind
Trump's crazy claim there may have been
wholesale surveillance of the Trump
campaign possibly including quote
microwaves that turn into cameras we
know this is a fact of modern life
microwaves you say Obama was spying on
Trump using microwave ovens to find out
about Russia Russia Russia meanwhile
Trump's boy Russia expert and frequent
flyer to Russia Carter page the second
name Trump ever dropped as a foreign
policy adviser writes a letter to two
senators claiming his phones were also
tapped doesn't that mean that Trump is
part of the investigation of his gangs
connections to Russia no reason to
believe there's any investigation by the
Justice Department says Trump's press
secretary he didn't get that from us
says the Department of Justice off the
record I didn't say no says Trump's
press secretary in return I said we
weren't aware of Russia Russia Russia
through campaign spokesperson hope Hicks
Trump gang members Flynn sessions JD
gordon denied meeting with the Russian
ambassador kiss lyac turns out they all
met with him then all fudge the truth
about meeting with him then CNN turns up
a video of kiss lake last October and
he's fudging the truth about meeting
with them Russia Russia Russia Trump
henchmen Roger stone boasts about
trading admiring messages with the
hacker Gucci furred 2.0
not only does the American intelligence
community believe Gucci fur is the front
for the Russian spies who act the
Democratic National Committee but stone
himself believes Gucci fur is
responsible for hacking the Democratic
National Committee in fact he wrote a
piece stating this her Breitbart on
August 5th which was nine days after
Trump's news conference when Trump said
of Hillary Clinton's emails Russia if
you're listening I hope you're able to
find the thirty thousand emails that are
missing Russia Russia Russia of course
days before he boasted about contact
with Gucci fur stone had already posted
about having a back-channel to Julian
Assange who posted the hacked DNC files
at WikiLeaks and last August stone
boasted he knew the DNC materials were
about John Podesta the presumption is
there's a middleman between the Russian
spy hackers and Assange and just about
the only thing Roger stone has yet to
boast about would be if he were that
middleman restoration then there's the
Trump pet Englishmen the brexit
conspirator Nigel Farage March 7
WikiLeaks releases documents reporting
to reveal CIA hacking tools March 9
Faraj is photographed coming out of the
London embassy of the nation of Ecuador
where for the last five years in the
actual embassy has lived Julian Assange
asked if he had just met with Assange
presumably moments earlier Faraj
actually says he can't remember why he
was in the building later a source in
Faraj is right-wing extremist political
party reportedly confirms Faraj met with
Assange that same day Assange holds a
news conference pimping his supposed CIA
documents and promising new revelations
March 10 business insider publishes non
WikiLeaks correspondence showing support
going back six years for Assange from
Faraj his political party by the way as
late as October 10th Donald Trump gave a
speech in which he bellowed I
WikiLeaks and Trump himself did not say
a thing about the presumed purloined CIA
docs as WikiLeaks released them and as
recently as February 25th Nigel Farage
had dinner with Trump Russia Russia
Russia and there's Trump and the Russian
fertilizer billionaire a Florida
newspaper now wondering why nine years
ago Dmitri Raible of Lev bought a Palm
Beach mansion from Trump apparently for
about 50 million dollars more than Trump
himself originally paid for it 50
million more and why twice during the
campaign and again as recently as last
month rival olives private plane landed
at a u.s. airport just before or just
after Trump's own plane landed at the
same airports Russia Russia Russia and
lastly there was the former Director of
National Intelligence James clapper who
was so pissed off that Trump claimed he
had been phone tapped the clapper went
public with the news that in January
days after he briefed Trump about the
existence of the Russian showers dossier
compiled by the former British spy
Christopher Steele Trump called him and
asked him to publicly say that dossier
wasn't true clapper wouldn't Russia
Russia Russia everything Trump touches
turns into another story about Trump and
Russia oops I take that back
General Michael Flynn the very brief
national security advisor who was paid
to appear at a gala for a Kremlin
controlled television propaganda outlet
the very brief National Security Advisor
who was paid to go to Moscow to be part
of a standing ovation for Putin the very
brief National Security Advisor who told
the Russians not to worry about
sanctions for allegedly meddling in our
election the very brief National
Security Advisor who either lied to the
vice president about Russia or got the
vice president to live for him about
Russia while he was sitting in on the
classified US intelligence briefings
Trump was getting as the Republican
presidential candidate Flynn was a paid
lobbyist for the nation of Turkey
turkey Turkey turkey which only
partially obscures the fact that Flynn
like Trump's call the clapper like the
sail of the Palm Beach mansion like
Faraj is visit to Assange like stones
contact with Gucci fur like kiss lacks
denial and Gordon's denial and sessions
denial and Trump firing the US attorney
personally banned by Vladimir Putin all
mainline back to Russia Russia Russia
resists peace